>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> And do it all.
He's a cartoonist, playwright,
novelist, screenwriter,
children's book author
and now memoirist.
And he has won all the right
awards for his efforts; a Pulitzer,
an Obie, an Academy Award.
Not bad for a guy who by his
own estimation was pretty inept
at most things growing up.
Feiffer was born in 1929
and weathered the depression
poor and Jewish in the Bronx.
He was the skinny kid,
the scared one.
Other kids had baseball
bats and could use them.
He had a piece of chalk
and to keep bullies
at bay he drew Popeye
on the sidewalk.
But the chalk wasn't magic.
The colleges he dreamed
of attending rejected him,
he had a miserable army stint,
and there was no end
to his mother troubles.
As he has said, there are people
who give you nothing but bad advice;
and unfortunately one
of them was my mother.
But Jules Feiffer overcame it all.
Eventually his village
voice comic strip
which brilliantly reflects our
culture angst was syndicated
in 100 newspapers.
He illustrated the
classic children's book,
The Phantom Toll Booth; he wrote the
movie Carnal Knowledge; the play,
Little Murders; and now in his
memoir, Backing into Forward,
he takes us through the terrible and
wonderful odyssey that is his life.
For more than 50 years that life has
been devoted to taking the powerful
down a notch or two; the
chalk is gone replaced
by sheaves of satirical comments.
Feiffer is an American treasure for
both depth and style of his work.
He's analytical and witty and
he teaches us about ourselves.
As one reviewer has said he's
the link from Lenny Bruce
to Larry David; from James
Thurber to Art Spiegelman.
Please join me in welcoming
Jules Feiffer.
[ Applause ]
>> Jules Feiffer: It's
a pleasure to be here.
I've just finished a gig with a
Norton Juster in the kiddy section
and talking about his
new children's book,
Theodorus Gorge, which
I illustrated.
And that illustrates the
varied career I have.
Most people know me as
a cartoonist of course;
but even from the beginning
as a cartoonist
as a village voice cartoonist
beginning in October of 56,
it's never been about the
pictures alone and in some cases,
never about the pictures mainly.
It's always been about voice.
And this was not known
to me at the time;
it was not thought
about at the time.
But a time I was a kid
being a cartoonist was all
that interested me and what
cartooning meant was not gag
cartoons as one found out
in New York, I love those,
but I couldn't do them and
didn't think in that vein.
I was a strip cartoonist and loved
the strip clones and the strip clone
with words and pictures; and
the comic strip at the time,
the newspaper strip at the time,
unlike today when they reduced
so miniscule that you can't have
anything complicated in them,
you can't tell real stories in
them, they're not very funny
and they're not particularly
well-drawn.
A few are like Mutts and one or
two others; and a few still try
to be profound like Eric
Trudeau and the everlasting
and ever brilliant Doonesbury
but there ain't much out there.
But this was a form before it got
so reduced in size it used to run
across the page; and I'm talking
about the years of my growing up--
the 1930's and 40's, before
movies were in Technicolor.
There were a few in color but not
many, before the age of television,
and certainly before the age of
electronics and iPhones and videos
and one kind thing and another.
And the comic strip was
a major American form.
The comic strip was part of
the culture no less than movies
or theater; the comic strip was
joked about on radio by Bob Hope
and Fred Allen and other comedians
because it represented a focal point
that everybody understood.
When you talked about Dick Tracy
or Lil Abner or other characters
at the time in the 1940's,
there wasn't a member
of the audience numbering into
the millions who didn't know
who those characters
were or Andy Gump.
This was a form that had taken
the country form the time
of its inception and
it wasn't that old
because the first comic
strips began about 1890, 95.
And so when I was a kid in the
1930's, it was still in the age
of its early developmental years
and early experimental years.
It was no more than 30, 40 y ears
old which is still pretty young
for a field such as that and it
was also at its most engaging
and its most-- the
adventure strip had just come
into play a few years before; and
strips used to run across a page.
There were five columns, six columns
and you could get detail and detail
and detail in the drawing
and there were any number
of brilliant artists working in them
who never thought of
their work as art.
Milton Caniff who did Terry
and the Pirates which was one
of the great combinations
of storytelling of text
and pictures uniting the two of
them, he was a teacher to me.
I learned virtually nothing
in the schools I went to.
I spent 12 years of public education
in the Bronx, learned zilch.
But when I opened up those comic
strips whether it was Terry
and the Pirates by Eisner, whether
it was Prince Valiant by Hal Foster,
whether it was Lil Abner by
Al Capp or Abby and Slats
which was also written by
Al Capp and illustrated
by a great illustrator
named Irving Van Buren,
this was my education as a kid.
And particularly Will Eisner's
coming out with in 1940, The Spirit.
These masters and they were masters,
never saw themselves as artists.
They thought artists was
kind of a fancy statement.
They didn't regard
what they did as art.
They didn't regard what they did
as being part of any serious game.
It was just the way they made a
living and if they saw themselves
as anything, they liked to see
themselves as newspaper men
in that Ben Heck, Charles
McArthur, tough guy stance.
They wanted to be seen and often
were as hard drinking, hard boozing,
gambling characters, gambling
and gambling, irresponsible,
meeting deadlines to the
last second with a hangover.
They liked that image of themselves
and the fact that these originals,
this originals art was
tossed, was destroyed,
was thrown out by the newspapers
once they had published it.
Nothing was saved though;
very little was saved.
It was not a shock to them,
they didn't view it as scant,
they didn't want their
work back, they didn't ask
for the originals back; they
didn't think they had any use other
than clutter and this went on for
years until a later generation
of younger cartoonists; namely
the generation I represented,
sold this stuff as something
these old timers didn't.
But I love these guys and what
I loved mostly was the act
of storytelling; how they told the
story, how they created character;
how different characters
even in comic strips spoke
in different ways, had different
styles of vocal representation
so that you could recognize them
even without seeing their pictures.
And not all of them did
that but the best ones did.
And this was part of my schooling
so when I, back in the 1950's,
began my strip, it was a long time
since I had given up on the notion
of being a traditional
strip cartoonist.
I had done after I got out of the
Army in 1953 all sorts of attempts
to get syndicated and to have my
work which looked like their work
and try to this is
what they do to me.
They obliterate-- I'm
being censored.
I wanted very much to be one of
the big boys and join the rank
of the big boys as
I grew up with them.
But I would try to do the more
traditional strips and send them
around to various syndicates
and they were all turned down.
And finally, I was left
without any choice but to move
in another direction because all the
traditional directions were close
to me.
And when I went to the Village
Voice to show them my work,
the work I showed them was
not the traditional work
but something I was trying out for
some time when I was in the Army,
outraged by the fact that the
United States Army would draft me
of all people.
I joined the Korean War
when I had other plans.
As Dick Cheney said, remember him?
When he was asked why he was not in
the Vietnam War which he was so--
rather his answer was,
"I had other priorities."
Well so did I.
I had certainly as many
priorities as Dick Cheney and most
of them were less lethal.
[ Applause ]
>> Jules Feiffer: But
not all of them.
And in the Army in reaction to
what I found was the oppressiveness
of the military and the mindless
of the military and
nothing has changed.
I started drawing as
a means of survival;
as a means of retaining my sanity.
I began to make up story about
a little boy four years old
who was drafted into
the Army by mistake.
Talk about metaphor.
And I called up Munro and it was
my first satire although I didn't
realize what it was going to be
and it was the first time I tried
to work in terms of cartoon
narrative, telling a story in words
and pictures the way comic
strips are supposed to be,
but also using the style in
the form of a children's book,
a children's book for grownups but
certainly a children's approach
where there is narrative
and there are balloons
and there is the storytelling.
And the storytelling takes a
little boy Munro through the Army
where he tries to explain his
only four and nobody believes him.
And the whole point behind the story
was to express my rage and my anger
at the policies of the military
and the policies of a country
for that matter in the
midst of a Cold War,
where mindlessness
often ruled the day
and good sense often was ruled out;
but to show it as I understood then
and have always understood,
to show it in innocent terms.
I understood that I
could not take a message
which at the time was quite
political and overt; take a message
that was countered to
the politics and notions
and establish institutional
feel at the time.
Take that and make it documented
rage; nobody would pay attention,
it wouldn't be accepted and
nobody would hear what I'm saying.
I had to do what I've
done my entire career
which was use sleight
of hand and fool them.
Basically seduce the reader into a
story that was going to be charming,
that was going to be innocent,
that was going to be fun
and fun was operative here.
I had to have fun doing it and so I
wanted it to be fun for the reader
but I also thought the
fun was a way of getting
through the point before anybody
knows I'm slipping it at them.
The fun was there to say
strong things that ordinarily
and polite company
back in the 1950's
and the heyday McCarthyism
were not acceptable.
So early on I learned in a sense
the approach that I have followed
in forms I've worked in the
following 50 years and that was
that you can't say it directly--
you can't make the point directly.
You must say it indirectly and
not obscurely, not obtusely,
you kind of sneak the reader
along and sneak the audience along
if it's a theatrical form,
not leading him or her
down a path they don't know
where they're going and often
as I write these things I
don't know where I'm going.
It's often I don't know
where I'm headed at all.
I heard Jonathan Franzen before
talking about his objection
to those writers who say
their characters take over
and of course he says
that's bologna,
the characters never take over; and
that in a real book you know exactly
where you're going; and now I
have to warn you about truth.
There is writer's truth which
is everything that I believe
as a writer, and then
there is nonsense
which is what every
other writer believes.
I've found that often with my
own work in all of these forms
that the voice I chose be
canned as in the cartoons a form
of improvisation; as one used to
see on the stage with Second City
of Chicago or Nickles and
Nay [assumed spelling].
We start with an opening line and
just follow the music of the word,
see where it leads you not
knowing and I often didn't know
where it was going and I knew
perhaps what I was aiming it.
Something viscerally told me
say if I was making a comment
about relationships, what
comment I wanted to make;
I just didn't know how I
was going to get there.
If it was about politics then it
was going to be the growing war
of Vietnam at the time
or Civil Rights.
I knew the point I wanted to get to;
I just had no real notion what
was going to take me there
so it's a combination of having
intent and then giving up the intent
to the innocence of creation.
And that innocence of creation when
you surrender to a higher truth
than anything the grain
will give you.
You give up this for this
and you let the gut lead you
and you let the gut do the writing.
And the gut will take
you down a certain path
and if it works it
will be the right path;
and if it doesn't you go
back and do it over again.
There are cartoons over the
years that I wrote and these were
at first acts of writing before
I drew them; that I would write
on yellow scraps of paper
and they would go perfectly
until the last panel; and
then I'd have no last panel;
I'd have no payoff.
I thought this was great stuff,
I have no way of ending it;
give up after a day or so
and put it away in the file,
and sometimes 25 years later
I'd go through that file looking
for something else, find
the cartoon, read it
and suddenly the last panel would
write itself but I'd have it
in a minute, in less than a minute.
And there it was a perfect cartoon
that took only 25 years
to put together.
And 25 years earlier I wouldn't
have had a clue how to do it.
These things do take control of you.
It's not you who are running it
although you do run it sometimes
and sometimes the things you do run
and do control are often
your most mediocre efforts.
Sometimes, often time I find
that the work that's most allowed
when I'm at it is the
work that controls me
as much as I'm controlling it.
That when I went into theater,
my first play Little
Murders, was a thesis play.
I was trying to say something
about the disillusion-- hello.
I've never worked in a
room like this before.
I was trying to say something
about the disillusion of authority
in America post John F.
Kennedy assassination
after November 22, 1963.
For the following year I
noticed increasingly a breakdown
of all forms of authority both
personal levels in families
and in institutional
levels in schools,
religion, certainly government.
Everything seemed to
be falling apart
as it had not done for many years.
Basically we had been when Kennedy
was President the same country we
had been from the days before World
War II after the depression on.
And suddenly it was all falling
apart and becoming unglued
and I was waiting just to read
the people writing about it
and hear some comment on
it and it wasn't happening.
And so my first play, my first
play came about purely by accident
because I wanted to
comment on this thing
that wasn't being commented on.
I knew the cartoon which was my
form at the time and my only form
at the time, wasn't adequate to say
something as profound as I wanted
to say so I began fooling
around with the idea of a novel
that got nowhere; and finally
in desperation as a play.
And the play began with me having
lots of notes about what I wanted
to do but really not
knowing how to go about it
and then simply writing it
down and letting it take over.
And it take over and it lead me down
these paths, some of which worked,
some of which didn't but became--
my first play taught me that I was
a playwright and from that point
on I engaged in this career of
where theater writing was every bit
of much fun and in many cases more
fun than writing a comic strip;
and that led me into other forms
and I should say it was all
about voice-- that the voice of
the comic strip which has to be
because of the form six or eight
panels, has to be [inaudible],
has to be restrictive, that's not
the voice you use as a playwright.
That as a playwright you've got a
lot of room to talk and you can talk
and talk and talk, and
you have monologues
and you can have a lot
of fun with language.
You can indulge in language
in theater the way you can't
and shouldn't in a comic
strip or in a movie;
and then writing a screenplay
which is unfriendly the monologues,
you've read another form so all of
these forms have different demands
but they're all about voice,
they're all about language.
When I started writing the
memoir Backing into Forward,
the book I'm going to talk
about and having directly,
I had to find a voice for
the guy telling the story
that the first person in memoirs
or in anything that's supposed
to be personal and
biographical, is only a substitute
for who and what you really are.
It's a front; it's an idealized
version of how you want to come
across because none of us including
me right now really sounds that way.
You're going to be saying
everything you believe on paper
but you're putting it
in ways that as far
as you can manage are the
most engaging to the reader,
the most seductive to the
reader, the most open seeming,
but all of it has to do not just
with putting it down it also has
to do with art and craft and years
of learning what people will take
and what they won't take, what plays
before an audience and what doesn't.
So all of it is a form of
like I said before a sleight
of hand; it's a game.
And it's that game that
I've never stopped playing
and still enjoy playing.
It says I'm in overtime
which means there's no time
for questions or is there?
There is time for questions.
Two questions all right.
Who has two very good questions?
Now I've got to tell you this.
It doesn't matter who
asks the questions;
I'm not going to hear them I'm deaf.
So it might be best if
you came right up here
and addressed them directly
and forgive me but I'm...
>> Audience question: First of all I
just want to say that I'm a big fan
of the book about the book about
the boy going into the Army.
I remember the panel where
he was sitting taking a test
and he was making a drawing--
a picture and the soldier
next to him was looking over
and copying that picture.
But I did want to ask you you're
talking about cartoonists,
and I was wondering how you
feel about animated movies
and television shows like-- that
work with Brad Bird, the Incredibles
and Ratatouille, and if that in any
way is similar to what was going
on with the [inaudible]
you talked about?
>> Jules Feiffer: Frankly
I don't know why--
I've worked in animation
and used to work in the 50's
and the 60'sto an outfit
called Terry Tunes.
I did Tom Terrific which
some of you may remember.
But I've never been interested
in animation as a form
and I never wanted to
do animated cartoons.
Munro as an animated cartoon
came around by accident
because it was Jean Diegh [assumed
spelling] who ran Terry Tunes
who bought it was very
happy with the results
and it won an Academy Award.
But I don't look at
animated cartoons.
I haven't seen Up, I haven't seen--
Miyazaki the Japanese filmmakers,
the one I've seen more of
and I think is brilliant,
and there's one called
My Dog Two about now
which is a wonderful piece of work.
And there's countless
wonderful things being done
and it will remain uncounted by me
because I'm not going
to see most of them.
It's not a film I have a
lot of curiosity about.
>> Audience question: I was
wondering what your experience was
like working with Mike Nichols on
the screenplay for Carnal Knowledge.
Was it a pleasant experience
with Hollywood people or not?
>> Jules Feiffer: Now for those of
you who've read the book Backing
into Forward you wouldn't have to
ask that question so I urge you
to buy the book else why am I here?
It's-- Carnal Knowledge was
originally written as a play.
I've sent it to Mike he read it
in 24 hours and called me back
and he said I want to do this but
I think it's a movie not a play.
What do you think?
And I said what about the language?
He said we won't have any trouble
with the language what do you think?
And I said give me 30 seconds.
And then he really put me
through when it came time to work
on the screenplay a tutorial on
how you turn a play script full
of long speeches as we talked about
what theater is into a screenplay
where we did have monologues
but didn't run nearly as long
as the ones in the play; and to
make it seem natural to the form
and it was from beginning
to end it was
about the most joyful
collaboration I've ever had
and I've been fortunate
to have a lot
of good collaborations
but this was the best.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.